[Applause]
we always say this podcast like every
correction is an over-correction
right this correction wasn't an
over-correction this election
like you could say from obama to trump
was the over
right right but it's not like we went
from
trump to aoc yeah bernie sanders or
bernie
that would be the other over this it was
almost like all right we've been
bouncing around a lot let's get it back
to the center everybody chill the [ __ ]
out
yeah it's like maybe we recognize even
subconsciously
our own tendency to over correct
and because of that we were just like
i'm tired of the seesaw
yeah let's just get a little stability
and you know what in four years
[ __ ] is going to be pissed off
again
yeah because that's what we do yep and
they go and the same [ __ ] are
pissed off because of
left-wing [ __ ] are going to be voting
for another trump s guy and the same
[ __ ] are pissed off because the
right wing
[ __ ] are gonna be po voting for another
bernie s guy but i think for these four
years it's almost like a timeout
you know what it means like yeah it's
like hey deep state cease-fire can you
just handle some [ __ ] so we could get a
deep breath yeah yeah you know what i
mean
like it says mommy daddy yeah blah blah
blah bullying me
like you know when your did your old
brother ever pick on you and your
parents split you up
like that's what this feels like it
feels like my younger brother telling
mom and dad
yo just put him in his room so i could
just chill for a minute yeah
which is why i thought it was like kind
of annoying watching everyone like go
out and like
celebrate dancing and celebrating and
stuff i'm like this is
like i don't really think it's going to
change anyone's day to day life like
don't worry it's nice seeing people
happy and stuff
yeah i went out to washington square
park and like saw everyone jumping
around yeah but also i was like
i don't really think this is going to
change like whose life is going to be
changed from this on like actual
what do you think the celebration
represented so
just the sentiment of him being in
office and the divisiveness yeah and as
a black person in america like
that's scary to me because i just don't
know how far people are willing to go
that disliked me so it's like just to
have
that feeling removed is coming
and that's enough for me to celebrate so
so i think there's probably people that
like
definitely support like i was in the
west village right i'm literally sitting
down with my fiance
eating brunch and i hear the horns start
do you guys hear the horns yeah i know
i'm sorry oh yeah yeah
new york was going oh but i'm in a gay
ass neighborhood
and the lesbos and the gays were
celebrating bro
snapping whistling they were going wild
and people were going for it and then we
were in washington square park a little
bit and [ __ ] was popping right
these people were celebrating and i
think that at least in like
marginalized communities or whatever
that term is like
there's probably that same sensation
yeah which is like
all right at least the leader i could
feel as if the leader of the country
doesn't hate me
now did trump hate these different
people
i don't think so personally but he might
have created an environment
that made people that hated them feel
comfortable yeah
right so i could see that relief but
then you see like a lot of like white
girls in college
they're like going crazy we did it we
did it's like
dude what like i i that it was it became
sports it did become [ __ ] sports
people
this is the world cup every four years
we all we you give a [ __ ] about the
world cup for a little while
that's why we're winning no but yo maybe
that's the thing it's like we never [ __ ]
with soccer because we got politics
no we don't need it y'all got a game we
got
live nothing gets done nobody ever
scores
but that's why when there's one black
guy on a team
when you guys mentioned before that uh
uh liberals are sore losers i mean so
winners
i kind of feel that no matter which side
won both sides would have been sold both
sides are sore bro
what what yeah i want to clarify with
what that is like
liberals are sore winners only based on
their own politics which is we should
bring everybody together we should unite
this should not be divisive and aoc is
out here
like [ __ ] stalin trying to take down
lists of people
that were going back
it just is hypocritical the reaction
yeah i tend to agree with a lot of
liberal policies but i
hate the hypocrisy of they act like
they're above all this [ __ ]
and they judge people who are doing it
they judge these guys at the trump
rallies they're so ignorant they're so
stupid
then your guy wins and you do the same
thing if you admit you ain't [ __ ]
fine but if the kind of liberal
zeitgeist is we're above
all of this we are for unity like andrew
said and then the second you get your
win
you act just like them that bothers me i
guess
maybe i didn't see it because i what i
saw and of course i was busy this week
and i i really wasn't paying that much
attention but i saw
um biden and kamala's speech and like at
that speech and the energy and the
messaging they put out
like i felt that that was great for the
nation i'm not speaking about buying
their comments trump if trump won and
said those same things i would have been
yo that's great for the nation yeah
and there have been times where like he
gave a trump gave an address and people
were like yo this was very united it was
one
maybe the last state of the union or
something even when he won remember the
stock market was plummeting as he won
and then he came out and gave a speech
that was pretty stable pretty i was like
okay
i'm going to give this guy a chance
because his speech doesn't seem crazy
seems pretty reasonable yeah and it was
comforting yeah so i just like the fact
that
you know it let's promote unity let's
promote
and 100 i can understand you don't like
the um
hypocrisy and that's that's the tricky
thing when it comes to like someone like
in
in my position is like i
agree with the sentiment yeah and i'm
annoyed by hypocrisy yeah
yeah and it's a it's a fine line to
articulate
because i have to preface it with yo i'm
on the same page we all got to come
together we all got to do this right
with the criticism of but y'all ain't
living that [ __ ] life
you